hey guys it is Tuesday and I'm talking
in this place because I'm a bit sick and
I'm completely sick
check out this kickflip [ __ ] okay
I'm okay first up we've got a piece of
my favorite kind of news new games the
studio behind IM setsuna tokyo RPG
factory is working on a new RPG lost
sphere Square Enix unveiled the first
details today much like I am setsuna
lost sphere is heavily influenced by
classic 16-bit RPGs features an
isometric viewpoint a revamped active
Time battle system and a story full of
the fields what sphere doesn't have a
release date yet but it will be coming
out for ps4 switch and PC digitally it's
set to arrive early next year if that
digitally part bummed you out Square is
offering a limited number of physical
copies for the ps4 and switched through
its online store for 50 bucks the
physical version will also include two
additional music tracks Jess I want to
take this moment out of news to remember
all the primates that have brought us
joy throughout the years donkey kong and
his penchant for Dame's and climbing
buildings king kong for much the same
Dunstan and him drunk what does this
have to do anything oh sorry over
watches maybe getting a new primate hero
right today Blizzard posted some images
to their social media with the caption
breaking update new details emerge about
possible fate of horizon lunar colony
several images are of emails between
scientists at the colony while this one
shows the specimen status of the base
with two names listed as not found
Hammond and Winston you may remember
Winston overwatch as guerrilla hero was
raised at the lunar colony along with
several other genetic experiments it
sounds like Hammond might be a new
primate hero coming to the game he may
be smaller however as one email is
concerned that it hasn't been seen for a
week and is lamenting the idea of having
smaller test subjects let's know what
you make of all this and make sure you
are subscribed so you don't miss out on
any developments finally we may have
just received our first good look at
their next Assassin's Creed protagonist
but the leak is a little unconventional
so it's cinematic or LinkedIn LinkedIn
nope it's a t-shirt only this month a
leaked screenshot reported to offer the
first look
Assassin's Creed protagonist but there
was a big boat in the way and it was the
whole thing now we've got this shirt
which was first posted on the Liberty
toad L animals Facebook fan page it
appears to suggest the new assassin is
named by yak reddit has also determined
that the hieroglyphics above the name
text read by yak so I guess it makes
sense you'd be softer yet to confirm
anything about the game including where
it takes place but an earlier report
pointed to an Egyptian setting with the
title Assassin's Creed Empire but may
screenshot leak was accompanied by news
that the game may be called Assassin's
Creed origins that aside Ubisoft's
ashraf Ismail who was a director on a c4
Black Flag did write on Twitter nice
t-shirt in reply to the news so this one
might hold water just like a book no
sorry boats don't hold water make for it
on top and that's everything we've got
for you today thanks so much for
watching be sure to hit that subscribe
button if you liked today's show and we
will see you again tomorrow